Welcome back everyone it's charlie this will be
my full marvel she-hulk episode 6 video there
were a whole bunch of easter eggs and references
and a big teaser at the end of the episode so i'll
explain what's going on if you're brand new
to the channel i'm doing videos for all the
episodes be sure to subscribe to get them careful
for spoilers from the episode if you haven't seen
it yet we'll work our way through shot by shot
talking about easter eggs and wtf moments as we go
along starting with the episode title it was just
jen a reference to her friend asking her to come
to her wedding as just jen not as she-hulk it's
also a bit of a call out on them not paying off
the daredevil teaser from the end of episode five
like it's just jen this week which she references
in the episode breaking the fourth wall talking
to the audience us saying but you thought this
was pretty inconvenient kind of hurting the
momentum of the series kind of in the same
way that weddings like this situations like this
are very inconvenient in real life so either they
wind up paying off the daredevil episode in next
week's episode or because they have this big hulk
king reference at the end of the episode they
directly follow up with that and daredevil is
later in the season we'll find out pretty soon
i'll explain what's going on with that teaser
at the end of the episode because it seems like
it's a combination of a hulkling easter egg like
hulkling from the young avengers comics and
because of the intelligentsia website which
is like a big tmz parody the whole intelligence
reference is a reference to the leader the samuel
stearns character who is the main villain of
captain america 4 new world order it sounds
like marvel has big hulk plans in marvel phase
5 between what's happening with captain america
4 the thunderbolts movie in like a world war hulk
style plot so i'll explain that later in the video
when we get to that part of the episode but i
think that's probably what's going on like the
leader's whole thing during the incredible hulk
movie which they made references to during the
episode like a lot of incredible hulk references
was getting hulk's blood and now someone wants
to get jen's she-hulk blood that person seems like
the leader but the actual episode starts with that
awkward wedding invitation from her friend to be
a bridesmaid with a joke about how lame it could
be like it's the lamest wedding invite you could
possibly imagine most inconvenient wedding invite
also which she calls out in that fourth wall break
nikki references the events of episode 5 with her
getting the super suit that we'll see later in
the season but she says that she doesn't want to
wear it she's not going to need it obviously she
will need it because we literally see her wearing
it in the trailers fighting with daredevil and
then working with daredevil it's meant to be a
comic book accurate version of her suit from
the she-hulk comics but they remind you that
it was one of several different outfits that
the designer gave her like she has a bunch of
regular outfits like suits and other dresses that
she can wear in her normal daily life which she
takes for a test drive at the wedding with the
regular looking dress they try to give her this
shulky nickname but i actually do not like it
that much so i am not going to call her shulki
you're free too if you want to though there's a
couple moments in the episode and they've done
it in previous episodes too where a lot of
the jokes are referencing things that people
are doing in real life like the trolls that are
going after she-hulk in real life the whole joke
about people having weddings on thursdays isn't
a fourth wall break but it's a reference to the
she-hulk episodes airing on thursdays on disney
plus like isn't it weird that it's on thursdays
what's the matter with fridays or the weekends we
find out her cousin chet is the dj for the wedding
later in the end credit scene with like the new
scenes that they work into all the episodes you
actually see ched getting it on with the bride in
the photo booth so go ched we also find out his dj
name that he's using is the inchesible hulk and
he wears a bruce banner incredible hulk t-shirt
jen also says that her friend knows her
entire family so that means that her friend
knows all about the bruce banner hold also people
didn't know that she was related to bruce banner
before this because she's been in the news so
much nobody is probably surprised that her family
has hulk stuff going on with it the other joke
with her growing apart from her friend in the
past like they haven't talked in a long time is
that her friend invited her to be a bridesmaid
just because she wanted her help not because
she actually cared about jen and because she
seems like one of those basic that just loves
the attention like she really gets off on having
titania there but then when jen does show up as
she-hulk she gets really pissed like oh you're
stealing attention for me so she's meant to
be like the worst bridezilla you've ever seen
you could also make a game of thrones wedding
reference too although this wedding not quite
as entertaining as the house of the dragon wedding
we just had like we just had the green wedding i
literally just posted a video for a little while
ago a little more eventful than the wedding in the
mcu here but that's just the way it goes inside
the game of thrones universe the big superhero
divorce case that she left mallory with is for
mr immortal from the comics he's part of the
great lakes avengers super deep cut some of you
may have read those great lakes avengers comics
his real name is craig hollows but they changed
his backstory a little bit for the mcu saying
that he took up a bunch of fake identities when he
killed himself and then resurrected so he's been
alive for a much longer period in the mcu married
to a bunch of different women and they play it up
for the comedy of it all like him killing himself
to get out of all the marriages because he hates
conflict so much in the comics mr immortals kind
of like an x-men easter egg they call him homo
superior like the final evolution of what humanity
will eventually become mutants are meant to be
like the next step so homo superior mr mortal is
like the next step after mutants in the comics the
whole comedy of his character is just like the
ridiculous chances that he'll take knowing full
well that he'll instantly resurrect so he can just
risk his life no matter what's no big deal the
only difference is that every time he does kill
himself he feels the pain like a normal person the
same way that wolverine feels the pain every time
he pops his claws one of the twists of his powers
though is that if he sustains a non-lethal injury
he'll heal at a normal human rate he only ends to
heals from full death so he could resurrect from
an infinity gauntlet snap if he was snapped during
avengers infinity war or like a full power blast
from it but if thanos wrecked his arm like he just
broke his arm it would take him forever to heal
it he makes a joke about the marriages that he
was in bleeding him dry like metaphorically fatal
he says he's tried marriage several times implying
that because of the way his powers work because
of how long he's been alive he's technically been
married more times than anyone else on the planet
i would say that kang might give him a run for his
money but technically kang hasn't been married
that many times he's had love interests like
ravana renslayer is kang's love interest in the
comics but he hasn't been married that many times
in the way he explains that he uses the twist
behind the way his powers work in the way that
the law is worded to get out of his marriages by
killing himself and then resurrecting and adopting
a new fake identity i think because of the whole
fake identity thing though that's why it doesn't
stick and why he's forced to make the settlement
when he shows them his powers by jumping out the
window and resurrecting on the car zoom and
enhance there's a qr code that you can scan
to get another free she-hulk comic book they've
been doing that in pretty much all the episodes
when she-hulk arrives at the wedding she breaks
the fourth wall again to complain about how this
was one of the few times she did want to show up
as she-hulk because all her old friends all these
people think that she's amazing now and she used
to be very unpopular if they make a reference to
the title where her friend tells her to come
just as jen like just jen they make a twilight
reference at her wedding rehearsal team jacob and
team edward saying that she's dated both of the
actors taylor lautner and robert pattinson in the
mcu before this so both of those actors are now
candid to the mcu as is the twilight franchise
and it's not a fourth wall break but she does
have a big reaction when titania arrives and they
explain the whole twist with her friend wanting
as many famous people there as possible being a
big fan of titania's her friend also references
the events of the previous episode with all the
different quote unquote businesses that titania
has and that was the whole reason why jen had to
sue her to get her to stop using the she-hulk name
the whole thing with a josh character that she
meets i think is just meant to be like a totally
normal dude in stark contrast all the weirdos that
she dated in the previous episodes because at the
end of the episode they also have a reference to
the fries which they referenced during her dates
like should we get these fries to go only this
time they played as like a really nice moment
like she's enjoying it and josh likes her for jen
instead of just for she-hulk i think we saw some
trailer footage with the two of them together in
a future episode so they like probably continue
with whatever relationship is developing here
we meet all of mr immortal's former wives who
are still alive like he references his first wife
who seems like she's long since dead all them are
different ages just because his powers have kept
him alive for so long like thus the wife from a
long time ago that left him a whole bunch of gold
one of them even had a biological kid with him so
that kid might also have powers we also find out
he spent one of his marriages as a gay man so i
guess that makes him buy technically in the whole
joke here is that he just hates conflict so each
time things became too inconvenient for him he
just bailed on the relationship by killing himself
because even though he bailed on a
bunch of debt in one of his marriages
technically he has this giant settlement money
like all this gold all the apple shares like a
bunch of other stuff it sounds like he's actually
pretty rich so there's no reason for him to avoid
debt they make the first reference to the
intelligentsia website which is a parody
of tmz in the mcu but they're playing it up like a
mcu gossip site just about superheroes and there's
all these trolls going after she-hulk but secretly
it seems like a front for what's happening at the
end of the episode and this researcher trying
to steal her blood like i said i think the
intelligentsia reference is to intelligence to
the leader's intelligence and it might actually
be the leader character who's behind all this
then i think we have another mcu first they make
a nintendo switch reference this could also be
product placement too like nintendo could have
just bought advertising in the she-hulk series
and they could just be working it in this way
we have seen fortnight in the mcu so like video
games do exist in the mcu but this is the first
time i think we've ever seen nintendo or switch
referenced in the mcu also mario kart reference
like they say the people have been playing mario
kart so she has to iron all their shirts now
like i said you can kind of think of this like a
bridezilla cinderella type of reference like how
much crap can we put on jen before she completely
breaks and hulks out just like in the cinderella
story she's put upon by her evil stepsisters and
then transforms into this upgraded version of
herself like jen transforms into she-hulk they
also reference espn which i think they've done
in the mcu before though they pay off a joke
about the mystery groomsman jonathan that she'd
been paired with who just her friend's dog which
they also referenced at the end of the episode too
in a bunch of pictures the joke about having to
resuscitate him and all the health problems that
the dog has is about toy dogs in general like
a lot of those types of breeds of dogs have a
lot of actual genetic problems just because of the
way they're bred then when mr immortal is offering
his wives the settlement he almost tries to kill
himself again because he doesn't want to make eye
contact with one of his wives like that's how much
he hates actual conflict they also pay that off at
the end of the episode too where you actually see
him doing it and they're holding up the counter
to 20 seconds when they're talking about the
settlement and they reference lake lawn mausoleum
that's a reference to mr immortal's great lakes
avengers in the comics she-hulk has another dance
montage this time she doesn't twerk like she just
dances to annie lennox but then she drunk dials
bruce banner hulk who hasn't come back from sakara
yet but this is meant to foreshadow him actually
coming back like bruce banner hulk will be in a
future episode so hopefully he will talk about
what he's been doing off planet and they have this
whole joke about her getting super drunk because
she's in jennifer walters form and apparently
the gamma doesn't burn off her alcohol poisoning
making her boot eventually getting into the
big fight with titania finally paying that off
proving her right she really did come to trying to
destroy her but the way they play it off she winds
up humiliating herself like she takes her down
easily and then winds up cracking her teeth which
they also pay off in the end credit scene with her
fixing the teeth at the dentist she also weirdly
steals the wedding cake on her way out like i'm
taking this because she also has those superpowers
she's pretty huge she also probably burns a bunch
of calories this is meant to show you that the
titania thing will continue into future episodes
like they'll continue to battle it out in future
episodes but she doesn't seem like she's connected
directly to the plot of the person trying to steal
her blood so they make another hulk reference
on the intelligentsia website the code name is
hulk king that's a reference to king hulk in the
comics which is actually a spin on the whole kling
character who's really a scroll he's like
the emperor of the scroll race from the young
avengers comics but he's a scroll that's the
whole thing that's why he's green he doesn't
actually have gamma powers his real scroll name
is doric part of this could be a backdoor secret
invasion easter egg because of what's happening
with the scrolls during that series in nick fury
but like i said this seems closer to what
was happening with the samuel stern's leader
character in the whole intelligence reference in
the intelligentsia name as the person is looking
in the digital readout of her biology and they're
preparing the samples to get her blood using more
upgraded hardcore methods so like i said i don't
know if episode 7 next week is going to directly
pay off this teaser or if they're going to follow
up on the daredevil teaser in episode 5 or if it's
going to be the same thing like those two plots
will wind up being paid off in the same episode
i'm assuming them paying off this plot will
be like the last couple of episodes though
like whoever this is will wind up being the main
villain of the series you can let me know in the
comments who you think this is like is it going
to be the leader or is it going to be someone else
we get a little teaser for mallory books backstory
she talks a little bit about herself but then it
kind of stops short so they'll probably reveal the
rest of that in a future episode the other thing
that's going on with the intelligentsia website
is that a lot of these memes and the hate posted
on shield the trolling is actually a parody of
what's happening in real life like a lot of people
in real life are trolling she-hulk so the show has
done this in previous episodes where they're kind
of calling out the trolls in real life throughout
the show nikki's hashtag friends with bros is a
science bros reference and then they just have
a joke about her having zero self-control like
we're not gonna tell jen about any of this stuff
which she immediately does like oh yeah we said we
weren't gonna do that but i did it anyway there is
no episode 6 post credit scene like no traditional
post credit scene just like episode 5 but just
like episode 5 they had additional easter eggs
in the end credits like the actual credits of
the episode those tend to change a little bit
in every single episode even if there isn't like
a regular post-credit scene most of the new scenes
are of the photo booth which they reference in
the wedding with her and josh ched then ched
also hooking up with the bride go ched there's
pictures of her dog the red haired person is
meant to be titania which they also show right
after this getting her teeth fixed at the dentist
then mr immortal serving out his settlement of the
eye contact with one of his wives for 20 seconds
so like i said they could follow up with the
daredevil episode next week or they could follow
up with the blood storyline you can let me know in
the comments what you think they're gonna pay off
or it'll be like a completely different episode
but i think the whole joke with this wedding
episode is it was meant to be like a one-off
interruption to that overarching storyline so
we will pick up with like the main plot in the
next episode call yourself a really good lawyer
in the mcu my full she-hulk episode 7 video will
post next week just like normal i have a bunch of
stuff coming up my full house the dragon episode 6
video will post on sunday be sure to enable alerts
for my channel so you don't miss any of that
everyone click here for my brand new house of
the dragon dance the dragon video and click here
for my house of the dragon episode 6 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!